my guest tonight is a five-time all-pro
running back
and although he retired from football
for the second time this past january
he stays busy as a philanthropist social
activist
business owner actor and as of today he
will be available playing the character
in the video game
predator hunting grounds
man he got killed fast please welcome
marshawn beast mode lynch marshawn how
you doing
how are ya
what are you laughing at why are you let
when you just see me you start laughing
why
i don't know what man right now i'm
laughing at a whole lot of different
i'm laughing at the way you keep
throwing your damn hair down like this
it's making me nuts it's crazy
like it's cool between that between
damn he got killed really fast all that
came in my mind was damn why the black
man always die
fast in the scary movies
let's talk about this predator in that
clip
predator kills you really fast were you
playing that when you died that fast
i was oh
god but that's really your voice
screaming right it is you screaming
yeah i did that they call it vo i
learned something
since the last time i seen you i learned
[Laughter]
you know you know i'm in the you know
checking off my bucket list and
vo is something that i didn't know about
but yeah
after i learned i threw that on there so
it worked out for the best
that's great well uh i i like you a lot
i
i i think you're fantastic you're a
gentleman
you're a great man so i don't like
seeing predator kill you
i just don't like it man i meant that's
just for the video game
okay good you bring credit see this is i
just was talking to your people
backstage i say i came
i came to the show i'm not sure if it
was the first or the second one but i
taught you something and i told you you
got a hood pass
and every time you came through the town
if you just said that
you'll be all right i remember this you
told me that if i was ever
in oakland i had a pass that i would
have street cred in
oakland you got to hit them one time
with the one time where they you hit it
and then you gonna be all right
say it again so i i want to learn it
again say it if you hit them with their
you itch
then you're gonna be on you itch
and then and then i'm clean then i'm
good i'm tell you gonna get so much
handshakes and dabs and hoods and
you know marshawn i don't get i don't
get a lot of those i don't get a lot
especially now during coven
ain't nobody getting a lot of them right
now you know i'm going to say something
you uh are busier now in retirement than
you've ever been
and i really admire you for this you are
everywhere
you're constantly working you've got so
much going on
um you're just you're an incredibly busy
guy what are you
where are you right now first of all
somewhere in the world okay you're not
telling me you don't trust me
you don't know i don't trust who
watching you okay all right so you're
somewhere
in the world i'm somewhere in the world
right now
okay i saw this picture of you this is a
very cool thing you do
um you gave out turkeys look at this i i
keep this picture with me at all times
because it inspires me you gave out
turkeys
in hawaii and california with your fam
first family foundation that is really
admirable that you do that um
and and really amazing and you're also
now
you're trying to get coding classes
you're trying to get kids
who are in need some coding classes tell
us about that
well they actually already doing it um
uh
uh shout out to shopify but uh
we put together this beast mode of
business where we brought in maybe
20 kids from the inner city who had no
idea about coding
so we gave them opportunity uh we know
provided them with
uh laptops and uh the kids gave them the
business plans
and they turned their business plans
into online businesses
uh you know for them to be able to
create and generate money
right and i would say at least maybe
five of the kids actually still have
sustainable businesses
that uh uh that they had uh made
but i mean throughout our foundation uh
we've been doing
uh coding for um i'll say about the last
maybe three to four years that's amazing
see the coding is just one thing
i mean we got architect uh classes where
these kids build models of you know
because we have a youth center now so
the youth center they build
models of what they want the youth
center to look like once we get our
coins right
and i mean you know just to put these
type of like architect i know when i was
a youngster i hear architect i'm like
out of here i don't know that he had
code and like code and what
uh a cheat code on a video game like
nah but they they
they dive into this and then they show
me something that
like the passion that they that they
have behind it i think it's more so just
you know people in position being able
to show them that it's actually out
there and able for them to do
yeah because i mean every time yeah and
also that it's possible it's po
and and i think sometimes people think
if they come from a background where
they don't have access to computers they
don't have access they think
i could never do that but when and then
they create a mental block
and if someone at any early age says
here it is and yes you can do this
there's no mental block
you're right that see man what i learned
uh
what i learned is like this these kids
imaginations
like if if you don't if you don't block
them see mine was blocked they told me
it was either going to be
sports penitentiary or or the casket
and then i mean you know i don't lost so
many people starting at the
early age of seven like uh you know i
might try to get this sports thing to
try that offend me and that was that was
that was where my mind had went but
everything else was
it was shut out for me because i never
had no inspiration to go be nothing
besides a athlete
but now i see that you know we get hey
you could go be an engineer like what's
the engineer or you could go be the
second a.d
on a on on a movie set like what's a
second a d and then i just learned
what's a gaffler and
you know all kind of that i mean now i
go and teach my kids that
and it's just like man the the more you
allow them to
show you that uh what they're labeled as
is not the truth yeah you'll be you'll
be surprised every time
yeah when you were when you were a kid
did people
try to tell you because you've shown
outside of sports
that you're this great force you're an
entrepreneur
you're you're you're just you know uh
you're so smart about creating these
different foundations you're making such
great decisions
did you know you were capable of all
that when you were a kid
or did people convince you that you
weren't able to do that kind of thing
nah man big dog i'ma tell
who all the way from elementary school
uh you know all the way through cal i've
been in special resource programs
and i mean it wasn't until about high
school when i when i finally got it like
man
that i'm gonna go ask for help right and
once i did that once i
once i put all that other you stupid you
got 80d
you got adhd you got all this but man
get that all right cool hey can you help
me and once i once i figured out
that can you help me then everything
else was just yeah i mean
small selling to keep it solid with you
right and now it's to the point where i
just got a uh
honorary degree from uh from princeton
so i mean
you feel me
from the town that could say i got a
degree from president after being called
stupid and you ain't gonna be you're
gonna be dead or in jail
blah blah blah blah blah man boss me
that's great that is fantastic that is i
mean that makes me
that makes that's the nicest thing i've
heard in
in a dark time that is one of the
greatest things i've heard god bless you
for that that is amazing
i'm glad that you're doing so well i do
have to ask you this which is
you retired then you came back then you
retired again
do you think you might un-retire a third
time would you give it another shot
or are you done done done
hey if the if if the situation is right
then yeah i mean it could happen yeah
but i mean i i've been uh
let me see i've been asking questions by
a couple teams
yep here recently right like are you
ready
i'm ready if y'all super bowl ready
that's that's what
that's what it'll take me to come out to
come and play
again yeah it'll have to be a guaranteed
super bowl
game for me really okay
okay yeah you know it's funny you say
that because that's my
no you didn't let me that is my i say i
will
because i get asked
look don't laugh i am a very talented
athlete
and how do you think i do in the nfl
marshawn be honest how long would it
last uh how long would you last
yeah i'll tell you like this if you came
and
suited up went out there
and played defense db
i think if you did that little hair whip
that you've been doing with your hair
yeah i think you will plus i think you
will bust a whole lot of heads
yes now you might get penalized to cut
you might get penalized a little bit but
i think you would bust a couple heads
with that little move right
right that's what i do and this is what
i fake them out
i go this way i go that way they don't
know where i'm going
they're looking at the hair they're not
looking at me because the hair doing
like this
uh let me ask you about this you've got
a
you've got a sports drink out recovery
tell me about recovery can this help me
marshawn i need help is recovery the
thing
let's get it zoom in on that huh yeah i
want to get i want to give this the real
treatment this is recovery
tell me could this help me because you
know me
marshawn i am a a top physical specimen
i push myself 100 all the time
recovery could this help me you damn
right it could help you
and i mean not just not just not just
from uh
not just from a long workout i mean it
can help you from a
long night of drinking or a long night
of
extra curricular activity
so whatever you feel you need some
recovery from i mean you know
i like being at the jack of all trades
and
i think with that juice you feel me that
recovery drink
i think you know it gives you a little
benefit to recovering from a lot of
yeah so i mean you know you could you
could get out and do a bus down
or you could bust down or
you feel me you could drink on something
and you take a little recovery the next
morning
and you be straight ready to do it all
over again yeah i mean i both bust down
and sometimes i bust him down and this
is what i need i need recovery
you know this is what i'm talking what
do i do i open it right here
all the good nutrients and and uh
right there you twist it and it gets
blasted in
i look so recovered i feel fantastic
you look like you're ready to do
something guess what marshawn stuff's
happening down here that hasn't happened
in five years five years
so now that's see now that's not the
buzz down now that's the bust
down now i'm ready to bust them down
[Laughter]
marshawn i'm gonna say this first of all
you can now play as marshawn check this
out you can play as marshawn in predator
hunting grounds on playstation and pc
and this is great a portion of all sales
of marshawn's recovery immunity drink
will be donated to his fam first
family foundation uh marshawn
you're one of my favorite people you
really are you're a great man you really
are
uh and you you uh
you're helping so many people you have
such a big heart you're such a big
talent and
you're hilarious you're funny you're
really funny and a great guy
so thank you very much for talking to me
man it's all good big dog anytime man i
appreciate it
and you i love you man i wish i had one
man i would have cheered
you right now it's all right oh it's all
right you know next time we you know i
just i'm telling you stuff's really
bubbling down there well i mean you make
sure you
you make sure you get home in one piece
so you could be so you could bust them
[Laughter]
all right marshawn lynch you're the best
thank you so much
right on big dawg you be easy man i
shitty in this hey you be easy big dog
hey marshawn that was really great uh
thank you so much and i'm glad you're
staying safe and i really am i mean
everything i say you
you do so much great stuff i'm really uh
i'm really proud to know you
you know thank you hey man it's a
pleasure big dog one of my favorite
human you're one of my favorite human
beings and so
always let me know how i can help okay
no problem big dog thank you man you be
easy now stay corona freak i'm that's my
plan i'm gonna go bust
down i gotta go this won't last long
marshawn
this [ __ ] is crazy